it came down to Allison Porter and Adam
Wakefield on Tuesday night's finale of
The Voice and the ladies stole the show
Allison and her coach Christina Aguilera
made voice history it means everything
the 34 year old singer showed she was
the clear winner with two epic
performances of the night
first bringing back friends and former
teammates kata Hey
Paxton Ingram and Ryan Quinn for a
powerful performance of hearts straight
on then the curly sue star took the
stage with Jennifer Nettles to perform a
duet of her emotional song unloved you
and after she was announced the season
ten winners Cristina storm the stage for
a screaming hug fest Alison caught the
attention of all four judges during the
voices Blind Auditions singing Blue
Bayou but she rightfully chose to beat
Team Christina the two formed an
incredible bond during the show and when
ET spoke with Aguilera ahead of the
finale she gushed over her contestant we
already we know each other now she she
can't get rid of me and after the show
the love fest continued I love people
that lead by example
and she was a perfect example for me as
you know a mother and an artist this one
right here just proved and earned it
more than anybody else I believe in my
heart you had your work cut out for you
and you did it babe I love you